this is my favorite part of the museum
what the hell is it
this is my father
in 1988 amiri baraka writes about black
author henry dumas dumas's power lay in
his skill at creating an entirely
different world organically connected to
this one the stories are fables a
mythological presence pervades they are
morality tales
magical resonating dream emotions and
images
this is the symptom of the way things
are
shifting ambiguous terror mystery
implied revelation
but they are also stories of real life
now or whenever
constructed in weirdness and poetry
to dumas's work baraka applied the term
afro-surreal expressionism
hello
so i'm off
donald glover's atlanta is about a place
a world
a world where something feels unreal
the characters see it they know it and
you can feel it too this place feels
weird to you right things are weird
something is off
something isn't right
[Music]
this sucks
what is it
is this real
no
no it is
not this video is sponsored by
curiositystream get access to my videos
and podcasts early and ad free on nebula
when you sign up for curiosity stream
today when show creator donald glover
said in a now deleted tweet that the
only thing that could compete with
seasons three and four of atlanta would
be the sopranos i would have laughed it
off as hubris if the comparison between
the two shows wasn't already so
appropriate elena is technically
excellent the filmmaking is precise
visually interesting and evocative the
camerawork is always intentional and
meaningful shots never feel out of place
it's well paced and edited and it does
all of this while being a show that
takes big risks in its approach to
storytelling the sopranos established a
set of characters and had a loose plot
that ran from season to season but it
was always more interested in exploring
interesting corners of its time and
place and the characters who inhabited
that space it slowly constructs a sense
of the atmosphere not just of new jersey
but of a particular culture and
experience there but it defied
stereotypes about the mob to present the
everyday life of its characters like the
sopranos atlanta has a loose plot but
it's much more interested in sketching
the texture of its world each episode
becomes a unique individual stroke that
together creates a portrait the episode
set within a local public broadcast or
the episode examining a mysterious
character or the one about a new year's
eve party at drake's mansion and many
others aren't about furthering the plot
they are about doing what the show is
best at which is filling in the essence
of a location time place and experience
but the portrait the experience that is
defined by these strokes is not sketched
in the style of realism but something
else it's justin bieber
there are the obvious things in this
world justin bieber is black there are
invisible cars strange men offer you
bites of a sandwich on the bus by the
sound talking about these elements
people frequently throw out the words
surreal besides the sopranos another
genre breaking revolutionary show that
atlanta is descending from is twin peaks
a show that also explored a location
where things felt off and which used
surrealism extensively to do so at one
point glover described atlanta as twin
peaks with rappers and when in the first
episode the man shows up and offers earn
a sandwich it puts off a distinctly twin
peaks kind of vibe
but surrealism doesn't tell the whole
story of what atlanta is doing unlike
twin peaks these strange occurrences
don't fascinate or garner the obsession
of the characters who encounter them
they simply punctuate a deeper more
pervasive sense of strangeness that
something is wrong is there an alligator
in there
yeah
what amiri baraka wrote about henry
dumas's work as afro-surreal
expressionism could easily be applied to
the show atlanta today i'm going to
write a manifesto i'm going to put it in
a local newspaper and see if it has
international impact over the years
and it did that's d scott miller who in
2009 with the permission of baraka
dropped expressionism from the term and
wrote a manifesto titled call it afro
surreal miller's manifesto would
identify and catalyze a movement that
has spread and grown significantly since
then what baraka and then miller
identified primarily in literature was
spreading into visual arts and then film
and tv i've been suspecting that donald
glover has been aware of african realism
for quite some time now in fact when i
saw this american video i pointed to it
i said that's afro surreal then i saw
kendrick lamar's um
all right video where he's got he's got
it's got cops carrying the car that's
afros real too miller's manifesto speaks
of unknown worlds emerging that
afro-surreal presupposes that beyond
this visible world there is an invisible
world striving to manifest the manifesto
says afro-surrealism sees that all
others who create from their actual
lived experience are surrealist so how
do you distinguish between surrealism
and atheros realism how are they
different right well the way the
surrealists used to do their thing was
automatic writing
seances drugs in order to get above
reality these people used to have to use
techniques and what i'm saying is if
you're dealing with an absurd fiction
every day of your life something that
you know is not real that you have to
treat as if it's real you're already in
a surreal situation without having to do
anything but we have to treat them like
they're real because that's the thing is
putting us in jail that's things that's
not us our our employment that's the
thing that that's getting people killed
right is this is this victim
sopranos and twin peaks utilize
traditional surrealism but they do so to
explore dreams psychology and
metaphysical reality they're using
surrealism to get at a reality that
exists beyond this reality but
afro-surrealism doubles back on this and
presents a reality again but it's a
reality that is itself inherently
surreal for marginalized people all you
have to do is just exist and you're in
absurd surreal situation i should be
able to use a hundred dollar bill okay
what happened to us was racist it was
weird no it was racism textbook
there's realism and surrealism
but
adding another prefix afro
black
black above reality that's what it means
so it changes the meaning of surrealism
as much as surrealism changed the
meaning of realism miller emphasized to
me that his intent was for this
manifesto to be an inclusive document
that afro-surrealism was for anyone
marginalized on the basis of class race
gender or sexuality it's not
segregationist
it's integrationist i wanted to include
everyone everyone so if you actually
look at the beginning of it it opens
with an indigenous mexican woman who
frida kahlo he quotes the prince
[Music]
song when did you know that you were a
35 year old white man
well i've always felt different i go to
the store and movies and just be
thinking to myself like why am i not
getting the respect i deserve and
atlanta explores identity from many of
these angles mr paperboy
what would you consider yourself
a rapper a straight rapper hell yeah
well i did some research on your lyrics
and they're actually very pro-sexual
spectrum oh pro-what earn is constantly
feeling out of place
i'm not alonso for the show's characters
there's discomfort in how they're being
defined by others based on race i didn't
choose black
or class so do you work with urn or you
an artist
no i'm sort of in between things right
now i stay at home mostly the now
infamous episode teddy perkins has many
interpretations but the one that seems
most resonant with the broader themes of
the show to me is the one that sees
teddy and benny as two parts of the same
with benny as an aspect of teddy's
identity he's ashamed of and struggling
against
i wanted to point to the fact that most
black americans are not
fully african like what you're doing is
you you are creating an identity
in order to pacify the white identity
that says this is what you are
even though you know four factors that's
not the entirety of you well you you've
never been to africa
no
you gotta go
man it's your motherland what are you
thinking this whiteness created these
things black people are like this asian
people are like this latino people were
like this
and we all had to adhere to these
fictions that were created for us i'm
just trying to stay real this navigation
of identity is tied to the show's
exploration of reality and what feels
real are black women considered
brunettes
i just held the balls and put them in
the jug
in this episode darius explains
simulation theory while van discovers
that drake isn't really at drake's new
year's eve party that all the photos
that were being posted on instagram were
with cardboard cutouts drake is a star
whose stardom is reinforced by a
projected artifice stars are just a
projection of what's actually already
inside of a model
what is real and why does everything
feel so strange
are donald glover and his team
intentionally creating an
afro-surrealist work with atlanta miller
pointed out that a lim smith the artist
commissioned to create the poster for
the show's third season explicitly
identifies as an afro surrealist and
that late fashion designer virgil abloh
who has collaborated with glover also
was familiar with the movement so it
seems likely that he's at the very least
familiar with the idea but whether or
not it's a conscious intent for the show
is hard to say as stephanie robinson one
of the lead writers on atlanta told the
guardian we certainly don't approach
episodes and say hey guys let's make
sure this script is surreal we're a very
specific group of individuals who are
probably more drawn to the unusual the
strange and the otherworldly it's just
personal taste not a verbalized mandate
or as brian tyree henry who plays alfred
said in another interview we honestly
didn't think atlanta was going to be
seen as a comedy but you have to be able
to laugh at the absurd to keep from
crying atlanta's afro-surrealism forces
me to challenge my assumptions about the
world it causes me to examine if what i
take for granted as normal is creating
an absurd reality for others in a
privileged position when trying to
understand the experience of all kinds
of marginalized people i think it's
typical to try to fit those experiences
into a simple narrative that alleviates
the burden on you where you're not a
part of the problem anymore or somehow
never were but in many ways those
oversimplified narratives end up being a
denial of the ongoing reality of
marginalization so the attempts of the
privilege to move past those issues can
just end up feeding into the absurdity
of the situation for the marginalized
but atlanta doesn't let you do that it
forces you to confront this absurdity
with its layers and layers of complexity
it forces you to consider the absurdity
of our own world it's not a show that's
here to provide an easy answer it's one
that asks meaningful questions it's a
show that says
you think you see what's going on
look again special thank you to d scott
miller for taking the time to chat with
me for this video it's oscar season and
if you want to see my reaction and
thoughts on last night's oscars you can
watch that right now exclusively on
nebula nebula is a streaming service
created by and for creators like myself
where we can publish our content early
and without ads and there's a bunch of
bonus and exclusive content just on
nebula you might have seen i just
launched a podcast called cinema of
meaning which you can listen to
everywhere but if you're a nebula
subscriber you'll get episodes early and
without any ads the best way to get
access to nebula is with the curiosity
stream nebula bundle curiosity stream is
a streaming service for documentary and
educational content they have tons of
great content go check out their library
they have great documentaries like one
of my favorites art and craft and the
amazing thing is they've partnered with
nebula so when you sign up for curiosity
stream using my link you'll get access
to nebula for free the entire bundle of
both streaming services is less than
fifteen dollars for the entire first
year it's a great deal you can get
access to it right now by going to
curiositystream.com
thomasflight or clicking the link on the
screen go there watch my oscars coverage
and get early access to the next episode
of cinema of meaning
[Music]
you